die 23 europäischen winterspiele in
pyeongchang sind beendet mit einer
farbenfrohen abschlussfeier
verabschiedet südkorea die athleten aus
aller welt
die uc präsident thomas bach lobt die
spiele als erfolgreich in jeder hinsicht
sie haben auch zu einer annäherung
zwischen nord und südkorea geführt zum
abschluss laufen athleten der beiden
verfeindeten staaten gemeinsam hinter
ihren eigenen flagge nein
auf der ehrentribüne sitzen eben
südkoreas staatspräsident und
us-präsidenten tochter ivanka trump auch
ein ranghoher general aus nordkorea
die nordkoreaner sollen sich am rande
der spiele offen für gespräche mit den
usa gezeigt haben
washington hatte jedoch zuvor die
sanktionen gegen pjöngjang weiter
verschärft mit 14 mal gold zehnmal
silber und siebenmal bronze hat die
deutsche mannschaft ihr bestes ergebnis
bei olympischen winterspielen erzielt